alors le pdt les mecs c'est une
tradition l'habitude oui ah bah là là je
sens que ça va
alors avant avant moi je veux bien mais
c'est dangereux quand même avant d'aller
au fond des choses je rêve ou le déni un
petit peu vos projets qu'est ce qui va
se passer là maintenant tout de suite je
sors donc mon livre qui s'appelle sans
famille seydoux a nommé le 15 novembre
je prépare l'olympia du à partir du 7
janvier je serai donc à l'olympia de
location sans locations sont ouvertes
c'est un très très beau publicitaire il
est très très bon jeu je voulais ça
qu'est ce que ça fait là bas c'est le
jingle plus mec qui fait qu'on a vu leur
plaie mexes et je vous laisse maintenant
moi je veux bien
cela dit ça me dérange pas tu vas
vraiment parce que je me déshabille
jeunes des années
je veux
c'est vous qui aurez vous
et je prends racine non
moi pas
oui
à toi
comment du
non non non non non non non non
ça fait débat alors là on va on arrête
tout s'arrête en plein air on va je ne
veux pas qu'on voit qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout des choses en revanche on va voir
là on atteint à scopitone lançait toudic
et au clip johnny hallyday c'est un
scoop it off c'est encore mieux l'après
guerre